all right let's get into audience
questions and at least one of them is
really funny this week hey David you
famously held Tesla stock for a long
time do you regret selling half of your
Tesla stock since it just went crazy
yeah earlier this week someone had told
me that I think it was during the Iowa
caucus live stream that day Tesla stock
closed at 780 and as many of you know I
invested in Tesla when the shares were
right around $200 and then I panicked
sold half of it when joe rogan had Elon
Musk on and Elon Musk smoked pot which I
don't care about personally but the
board went crazy and it looked like it
was trouble for Tesla I panicked sold
half of my stock and I say before I
don't know what what I'm doing with
stocks this is why I really don't invest
in individual stocks I only have I think
six individual stocks and otherwise
almost all my money is in mutual funds
and bonds because I just don't know what
I'm doing I don't know I I do things
like panic sell so do I regret that I
sold half of the Tesla stock and since
then it must have been at about 360 when
I sold half of it and now it's you know
it went it got close to $800 per share
during this week yeah I mean to some
degree I regret it but at the same time
I know going in individual stocks for me
are like gambling in that I don't know
when to buy I don't know when to sell
I'm too busy with other things to really
be picking stocks so the amount of
regret is relatively small I also I
didn't invest so much that if I had held
all of it right now
my financial situation would be
drastically different and by the way the
things I took it out of when I sold that
half I put it into other stocks that
have done not as well but also well so
I'm I don't live in the past to the
extent that I can avoid it I have mild
regret but I think the lesson here is
whatever made me buy the Tesla stock to
begin with years ago when it was at like
190 or 200 a share that didn't
fundamentally change when Elon Musk
smoked pot with Joe Rogan threatened to
take the company private at 4:20 a share
to Saudi buyers
something like that even though that was
a violation I guess of SEC law but hey
you know I mean listen doc we're
starting at nitpicky or you know
whatever else that didn't change the
promise of the company and now this is
one of the most valuable car companies
in history and that's really what I
should have focused on in the same way
that my mutual fund strategy is you just
buy and hold because I guess I believe
in the future of the world economy when
I diversify across you know total
international stock market index I'm
basically taking a bet on I believe in
the future of the world economy and if
it goes away because the climate
implodes and we have no more planet I
probably won't care that much about my
mutual funds because we'll all be dead
or whatever
in the same way whatever made me think
this is a good investment for the long
term it didn't have to do with whether
or not Elon Musk was smoking pot with
Joe Rogan so in retrospect I should have
just gone with the initial reason I
invested in Tesla which I thought I
believed that it was a car company that
would become a successful staple in
electric cars that has happened I think
80 or 90 percent of electric cars on the
road today in the US or Tesla and I
should not have panic sold I regret it
but I'm not living with my regret is the
way I would answer the question